[Applause]
cool American stoners it's gonna be here
schedule one narcotic salsa so this is
the one we're supposed to be sober right
so - not scam I got very courteously so
I had to become okay with the shape Mike
met again changer someone yesterday
called me in Korean foot doing with it I
am looking for my soulmate and I haven't
been able to find her yet maybe that's
what I do with it I have yet to be there
something because they think it's her
fault she needs to get out
she's like loser gentleman I think I
could do better I'm looking for a woman
who is intellectually stimulated by the
mental exercise of fighting the
attractive like a girl
puzzles as well holy [ __ ] you're wearing
that tonight okay it's all this I can
tell by the way you guys are just
staring at me
everyone feels really safe right now it
kind of makes me insecure something
about my aura that inspires confidence
in others I think of many people I feel
like my physical abilities right now
what inspired that in you yeah you're
both smart and I'm street smart
oh you're smart and when it's not
measurable unbearable
I'm competing for you baby you're not
smart baby dumb and that's our you're
committing algorithm aggravated assaults
it's not punching me in hurts
I am working out I just want to get
enough strength so that if a girl Japan
on my chest I don't the big step
backwards I go to the gym and I work out
all the ways that people haven't
reracked and that way they gave the body
of an [ __ ] the defeat of being Asian
a lot of people make fun of us because
we dogs which I understand to be very
shocking because in America that dogs
treated like family members but in Asia
we treat our family members like family
members we just love her grandma
let's see the baby girl which
intradermal in their bed
step out there make sure it's a good one
I try to date as an Asian man at run
things Asian women are beautiful don't
be patient men are beautiful doesn't
even make any sense
tiny asian women are created mean
[ __ ] I'm a rural part of the sexy
process please stop kind of skipping the
sex with me I'm sure will be very
beautiful
here's the best part - I am on recess of
course and my Guardians earrings I
always smell it smell it the way in here
I thought I need people to like this $50
the first big people for their skin I
think people for their souls call me
when you get to my level I try not to be
racist but of course I do have bouts of
racism like I was on a plane and I saw a
dude I was reading
and honestly kind of freak me out but
then I thought pull the corner of the
page to the back of his head and I was
like oh thank god it's got future plans
[Music]
[Music]
the engine is races to me I'm like a
respectful people who teach themselves
people like me and I think it's weird
that a lot of like dudes named tanner
another the what your white love [ __ ]
it should be like hey this is my Mexican
friend tanner
that's my black friend Candace
something's showing love the weights
weights great I think other white pride
is a good thing but a lot of people do
it incorrectly throwing it's like the
Nazis and a confederate flag that number
instead of building a castle orderly
that's always right this is racism you
don't see white to be racist like me the
juice soon - stop - good person twice
what the time about there's a lot
confusing stages in English there's the
phrase don't drop the soap that's not
helpful and you're free branding on that
brace don't pick up the soap think it
drumstick so that's your line for the
bending over or they will get you if you
don't drop the selfie something irate
just travel to clean the Angela Athens
what were these prisoners like and I get
that kid across the soul
does he have a bowl of time to this
humma phobic dude is a dude was so lucky
when I came can you imagine that was the
gender we were attracted she wasn't
attracted to his back Bo can't imagine
in spring oscillate of losers what I do
that's like I do love the women I think
they are the sexiest gender in the human
race then playing in the top 72 else
figured that this year going like that
sorry sir beautiful like man she's
gorgeous but is there person for this
bigger and hairier West I guess that'll
never happen straight [ __ ] stickers
not really a dating app that's one like
a smartphone game where if you win you
get that touch a girl I think women are
very beautiful they try not to stare at
them because women have rights
that can be afraid of maybe I try to
make my mom to go to the Starbucks they
expect that is getting into ERISA Sean
so I said using a pseudonym I started
going by the day ching-chong big bump in
there they got to say it's on the cup
that's not your day excuse me sir I come
from a long line of proud big balls
do not insult my heritage where you
would dig up that the guys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]